welcome to that Q&A session or four
speakers okay yeah welcome to the
tutorial on extended formulations we do
this together with Hamza and Prasad and
well we have four lectures divided by
three so well the planners will give
everybody one one dot X lectures doesn't
have to be the same X doesn't have to be
positive probably we'll see we'll see
how this turns out
so the plan is that I'll give some
introduction into extended formulations
for linear programs then Hamza is taking
over and these are going to talk about
how you can have extended formulations
for semi definite programs and what
happens in that case and the plan is
that Prasad is going to talk about two
lower bounds that he are not co-authors
proof for sub LP setting and also some
SCP setting which is a pretty recent
bound okay so let's let's see so what is
an extended formulation in combinatorial
optimization what we what we love to do
is we love to look at polytopes and
usually they're given in some inequality
description and there's a different way
how you can represent polytopes
you can imagine that you're adding some
extra variables and now you're looking
at inequalities in a higher dimensional
space that also contain these extra
variables and now you you may want to
write your your polytope as the set of
all X so that there is a way to set your
X our variable so that that that other
system of linear inequalities is
satisfied and you if you think about
this geometrically then this means that
you have your actual pull it open but
you've write it as a linear projection
of some higher dimensional polytope okay
so so why should you go to some higher
dimensional space the idea is that there
are many examples where
the original polytope needs
exponentially many in constrains but
it's possible to go to some higher
dimensional space and only use fewer
inequalities let's say polynomial many
inequalities if the study of extension
complexity is well by how much can you
reduce the number of inequalities by by
going to some higher dimensional space
and so more formally the the extension
complexity of a polytope it's the
smallest number of inequalities that you
need so that you can write your poly
tope as a linear projection of some
higher dimension polytope with that many
inequalities and you're kind of ignoring
the dimension here you only count the
number of inequalities okay good so I
have to pay a copyright fee for every
minute that I'm showing this picture to
sam Fiorini so let's move on and we're
gonna be trying to be an expensive gonna
be an expensive talk ok so what's what's
the motivation okay so imagine you have
the spanning tree polytope so the
spanning tree polytope it's the convex
hull of the characteristic vectors of
all the spanning trees and then let's
say a complete graph maybe maybe this
one and that means like every of those
corners would be would correspond to one
spanning tree and imagine you want to
use linear programming to optimize over
that that Polito to find the cheapest
spanning tree then the problem is that
this poly tope has exponentially many
constraints and it also also has
exponentially many many vertices but
there is a way how you can write this in
a higher dimensional space by adding
some let's say flow variables and only
have n cubed many many many inequalities
and then instead of optimizing a linear
function over the actual poly tope you
can just optimize the same linear
function well added with some zeros over
the higher dimension poly tope and you
get your answer so you can get your
answer by just solving a
a program that has polynomial size
that's a nice thing on the other hand
later we'll see some lower bounds on the
extension complexity and a lower bound
on the extension complexity kind of
implies that there's a certain class of
algorithms that you cannot use to solve
your problem so in particular you cannot
solve your problem by just solving one
polynomial size linear program so that's
a little bit the motivation question so
far so I thought I'd start with one
concrete example otherwise things are
maybe a little bit too abstract and my
examples not going to be spanning tree
but my example is going to be the
knapsack polytope
okay so knapsack probably all of you
have seen that problem here we go you
you have n objects and every of those
objects has some weight imagine that
being some positive integer and it has
some profit PR and you have a knapsack
in the knapsack has some capacity let's
say capital B and now the goal is you
want to find that subset of your items
so that the sum of the weights does not
exceed the capacity of your knapsack but
you want to maximize the sum of the
profits just good old knapsack okay so
it's a very well understood problem
it's np-hard weakly np-hard to be
precise and they're pseudo polynomial
time algorithms so if if the weights are
bounded bounded by the polynomial in n
that then you have a pony overtime
algorithm in particular there's also an
F Peters for the problem what's a little
less known is that there is also kind of
a nice extended formulation for it and
let me explain this so if you look at
this object here this
is the convex hull of all the
characteristic vectors of solutions so
that well these are feasible knapsack
solutions and if you look at the convex
hull then the extension the extended the
extension complexity it's less than you
might think it's bounded by n times
capital b and b is the size of your
knapsack assuming that the weights are
integers okay so this kind of looks like
the running time of some of that pseudo
polynomial time algorithm if you think
about it and I want to explain this
and in some sense when it's an np-hard
problem so you don't expect that there
is some something polynomial in n that
won't happen but there is a there's a
pretty neat extended CIM extended
formulation any question ok and the
trick is that you actually you just use
that dynamic program that's behind those
pseudo polynomial time algorithms and
here we go ok so you'll probably have
seen this this type of dynamic program
before this is the dynamic program that
just you know is the algorithm to solve
nab second times n times Capital V and
you just need some table entries in your
dynamic program let's call this it's a
table entry depending on some index I
and some parameter W and this is just
supposed to be like the maximum profit
that you can get by taking a subset of
the first items so that their weight
adds up to precisely W and this is the
formal definition of that ok and there's
a very simple way how you can just get
every entry in this done every of those
table entries you just take the better
option off well if I take the item then
I still then I get the profit from the
item but like the weight that
have left decreases by the weight of the
ayah I fight them and if I don't take it
and I just copy-paste the entry from law
from from from the left hand side column
okay but so this is a dynamic program
and this directly can be translated into
an extended formulation as follows
okay so we have table entries for every
index I and every every W that goes
that's between 0 and the capacity of the
knapsack and let's let's arrange them in
in like a matrix form so this is index
index zero index 1 index index 2 and so
on and this is weight zero weight one
way two and so on and let's create a
network as follows waiting two types of
edges we consider like every of those
nodes as a state and we're adding a
directed edge between a state and the
neighboring one and we imagine that we
give a cost of zero to this edge and
this these edges correspond to these
decisions that I don't want to take the
item okay
so we're also adding edges between
between state I minus 1 comma W minus WI
to the to the state i W and these are
the edges that correspond to the
decision that I actually I want to take
the item so I want to go from this state
to this state and I'm making some profit
if I'd if I make this decision and the
profit is precisely the profit of of the
add item okay and if you know think
about this then well then I can also add
I can add a source and I just connect
the source to to the state to my start
state which is just I equals 0 and W
equals 0 and I add a sink
and the sink has cost zero ages profit
zero edges from all the states for I
equals n and W at most the capacity
going in and now there is a there is a
there's an easy by action between every
subset of your items so that the sum of
the weight is at most the capacity of
the knapsack and and the path in the
network okay this is actually just with
your dynamic programming your dynamic
program is doing your dunnock program
just looks at the the maximum cost path
from s to T in this network okay now we
have everything nicely in place now we
just need a linear program that finds us
the maximum cost path in this network
okay
and what that is a well-known thing
essentially the idea is you want to send
a flow of capacity one from s to T and
you want that the cost of that flow is
maximized so okay so this is our network
and this is just the linear program you
are you need some flow variables that
are called that Y and the flow it well
it should be a flow that sends a unit a
flow of one from the source to the sink
and at every other node you want that
what's coming into the node
- what's coming out of the flow is zero
okay so this models your floor yes
Prosser
okay so item is for example item two
edges are these three green edges they
correspond to the decision that you want
to take the IE puts to item okay so we
have this flow of value 1 going through
all Network from the source to the sink
ok and now there is there should be the
projection back on the other knapsack
variables the way we can do this is like
the projection you could just do the
following you have these variables that
course these flow variables that
correspond to should I take the item or
not and you just sum them up and that
gives the decision whether I should take
the item or not ok so there are some
things that you would actually need to
prove you would need to prove that all
the extreme points of this polytope they
are integral they're basically two ways
how you can do that you can stare long
enough at the constraint matrix you see
that you have 1 and minus 1 and 0
entries and the matrix is they actually
totally unimodular a more direct way
would would be that you say well if I
don't have an extreme point then if you
look at the residual graph of the flows
you would need to have a cycle then you
can change the flow and then I mean
you're showing that you don't have an
extreme point ok good so if you think
about this geometrically these are your
extra variables you get some something
in the higher dimensional space where
you have those flow variables and you
give you project things down on the
knapsack variables then you have a
beautiful 0 1 polytope ok
so easy okay okay so um the size of this
linear program its waltz basically the
size of the network so it's it's o of n
times B that's the number of constraints
you're having also it's in the number of
variables that you're having okay by the
way there is there's a nice open problem
here which is the following okay so I
mentioned that there is an F Peters for
knapsack
so is there also some type of F Peters
in terms of extended formulations so
what would that mean well let's look at
the the knapsack polytope so this is the
convex hull of all the solutions to your
knapsack problem but maybe now the these
are necessarily large numbers you don't
want to write down this network which
would be joint Alanya which would have a
giant-sized you want to approximate this
pollito so let's say what you want to
have is you want some other polytope
that's inside of that nasty knapsack
polytope and you want that if it's
scaled by 1 plus epsilon then it
contains your knapsack polytope why
would that be nice it would be nice
because if now someone comes down the
road and and he gives you some cost some
profits for the items you could just
optimize that linear function over K
over your your small linear program k
and you would get a solution that's a 1
plus epsilon approximation to the actual
knapsack problem and we know that there
is action algorithm for that so the
question is could you could you get an F
Peters for knapsack but just soul being
one linear program okay so what I would
like from this linear program is that
the size should be polynomial in N
and in one of our Epsilon so that would
be yes okay what Bienstock shows is that
you can get a kind of a pitas
approximation using a linear program I'm
sure we'll see the show rowdy atoms
hierarchy you could basically later in
this this workshop and you could
basically use the Sharada atoms to get
this type of result but this this does
not give you an F Peters type
approximation and if your idea is that
oh let's just take the weights and let's
just round the way it's a little bit and
then have that that compact LP that I
just showed that would not give this
result because you would get you might
get slightly infeasible you might have
some solution that's just barely barely
on the border and if you round some
weight and suddenly this may be become
infeasible okay so this is a nice open
problem if you have a
I don't have any non-trivial lower bound
except like dimension or so okay so you
have three enough months to solve it if
you like would see at the end what comes
up okay so this is this is my
introductory example and now I want to
talk a little bit about some structural
background behind Hicks and extension
complexity okay so I cannot talk about
the extensions of complexity without
talking about select matrices and here
we go so let's say you have some poly
tope P and imagine you have it given in
two different representations so on the
ones one hand I tell you all the
inequalities describing that polytope
and on the other hand I give you the
Birdy's is describing the Polito okay
yes before we go to slack thank you so
so that previous example was essentially
no the extended formulation implies the
existence of an algorithm okay okay the
existence of the dynamic programming
algorithm implies the the extension
complexity yeah in some sense if you
show a lower bound on extension
complexity it shows that you know this
simple class of dynamic programs can't
exist for that problem it's like where
you're for like a polynomial number of
states and you have some decisions and
you always take the maximum over
something that like linearly depends on
your cost function something like this
function themselves kind of polyhedral
yeah
does running the simplex method over the
lp you get model what happens in the
dynamic program like if you work so if
you have this extension this lift you
get from the polytope you could run the
simplex you could solve the LP some you
know okay for this one well it depends
probably depends what rule you have in
the simplex method
yeah we've just someone volunteered for
a different tutorial on Thank You Misha
okay other questions
okay so uh Lake matrices yeah okay
so slack matrix it's a it's a giant
matrix where you have a row for every
inequality describing your polytope and
you have a column for every vertex
describing your polytope and the are the
entran the are the entry that you have
it gives the slack that this vertex has
with respect to that facet so it's well
depending on the scaling but it's it's
it's proportional to the distance of the
vertex to to that hyperplane okay so
this is a giant matrix with only
non-negative entries that's important
okay
the second definition that's gonna be
important it's the non-negative rank so
first of all the usual rank of the
matrix it just means the following you
want to write a matrix as the product of
two matrices and you try to minimize the
number of columns that the first matrix
has and the number of rows that the
second Matrix has but they're
non-negative rank it's a restriction
where you're forced to use only
non-negative matrices so then the
non-negative rank it's going to be
something that's always at least as big
as the rank but it may actually be a lot
larger okay okay so why am i mentioning
like the slack matrix and the
non-negative rank and there's a
beautiful theorem of Jana caucus from
the late 80s showing that actually if
you if you look at the non-negative rank
of the slack matrix of a polytope that's
precisely the same as the extension
complexity of the polytope so if you do
figure out the non-negative rank of the
slack matrix you have precisely the size
of the smaller cell like LP modelling
your problem okay the first time you see
this this is like why should this be
true it does make a little bit more
sense if you look at the proof my
students never believed that when I say
that
okay so okay let's let's see the probe
and the probe obviously has two
directions and this is the supposed to
be easy direction okay let's say this is
your slag matrix and you managed to
factor it as u times V R these are
non-negative matrices so how do you get
an X extended formulation out of that
well let's say this is your original
polytope it's a X at most B now you take
this and you slightly modify it you
write it as all X so that there is a
non-negative vector Y so that ax plus
the left vector times that non-negative
vector equals B so the inequality turns
to an equality so why would that make
sense well first of all if you have a
point that that should be in the Polito
that should be in P let's say a vertex
then you can actually pick you can make
a choice for Y so that this is true and
you just if this was the Jade vertex
then you just pick the Jade column of
the right factor and you plug it in here
and then a product of you know this row
and that column it's precisely the
select that you need to make this
inequality okay on the other hand if you
have a point that's not supposed to be
in the Polly table so you have upon XO
that for some row I say I X is bigger
than then bi then you know whatever
non-negative stuff you're adding still
this is bigger than that so there's no
way of getting inequality so that
actually means that if you if you have
that factorization that gives you a non
negative that gives you a representation
where well I'm not actually saying much
about the number of equalities but the
number of variables doesn't go up too
much and that also bounds the well you
can reduce things and then you also get
an extended formulation that
that has that bound on the number of
constraints little GT okay so there's a
second direction so that last thing is
because the U is a nothing the matrix
factorization and the y ver assuming has
to be nominated that's why that left
under bracket yeah yeah [ __ ] it okay
maybe slightly more interesting is why
did the other direction works okay
suppose this is your poly tope and you
have a nice extended formulation that
has only few inequalities are
inequalities so why does it mean that
you can can get a factorization of the
slack matrix that has only our columns
and one matrix and our rows in the other
one okay so let's think about what we
actually need we need non-negative
vectors UI and VJ that both have
dimension are they're non-negative both
have dimension R and we have a vector UI
for every constraint I and we have that
vector VJ for every vertex XJ of the
Polito so and somewhere from somewhere
we need to get those negative
non-negative vectors and if you look at
the inner product it better be it better
be the slack that this guy has with
respect to that that inequality and this
is where we get things from so that
vector for UI we get it as follows we
look up in that higher dimensional space
and that higher dimensional Polito and
by a pedo ality you can figure out that
there has to be some non-negative
combination of the constraints that
gives actually this vector here
otherwise this would not be the
projection of this thing okay and you
take those non-negative you take this
corny combination there's non-negative
combination that you
you use that to fill your back door for
this for this this constraint okay
similar game here for the vertex you
look up into that higher dimensional
poly tope there's gonna be you're gonna
hit at least one point here and you now
look at this piece of a point what are
the selects that this point has with
respect to those are many constraints so
you get are non-negative numbers and you
use these are non-negative numbers to
fill that vector V J okay and now you
just multiply things out and then kind
of more or less magically you get the
slack on the other hand now if you think
about the picture then well you take it
you take a coney combination you take a
non-negative combination of some slack
values that you're getting like the
selects of this thing with respect to
this one kind of makes sense if you look
at a picture
questions oh good so this is this is a
Jana caucus the order okay so if you if
you talk about the the extension
complexity you may want to show an upper
bound that usually you show by giving
some construction or the linear program
you may also want to show some lower
bounds showing that a actually for some
some poly topes you need a certain
number of of constraints even if you go
to a higher dimensional space and I want
to talk about kind of the simplest
method how you could possibly get a
lower bound okay and that's the
so-called rectangle covering number okay
so here's the principal imagine this is
this is some non-negative matrix as and
if I didn't mess up then this should be
this should be non-negative
factorization u times V should give us
now I'm going to convince you that the
the non-negative rank of this matrix
that is something you can actually do
the following you can forget the numbers
and just remember where the numbers are
zero or whether they're positive you we
don't have negative numbers so okay now
if you look at the first row of U and
you look at the first color the first
column of U and the first row of V and
you look at the positive entries then
they actually induce what's called the
combinatorial rectangle and in that
communitary erecting of the matrix is
only gonna have four step entries
there's a positive entry times a
positive entry it's going to be positive
no matter how many nonzero entries how
many non negative entries you're adding
okay so if you do if you you know
complete the reasoning then you get that
actually if you only had our many
columns then you can actually cover
all the positive entries of your slack
matrix using only our community
rectangles the particular those
community rectangles are not going to
cover any of the zero entries okay so if
you managed to to show that your your
slack matrix has a rectangle covering
number that's at least say two to the N
or two to the constant times n then you
have your lower bound this is kind of
nice in the sense that it's it's
something more combinatorial you don't
have to mess around with the numbers you
just have to like show lower bound on
the pattern of this support data okay
good selecting a covering and these
notions like comment or rectangles there
is a dis an area in theoretical computer
science where you may have heard these
words before and these terms kind of
come from what's called commune
communication complexity I think there
was a workshop like two workshops ago or
so okay so there's indeed there are some
beautiful connections to communication
complexity if this is just back in your
dark undecorated times let me try to try
to remind you what that is okay so the
general setting in communication
complexity it's the following there's
some function f that depends on two
inputs let's say some input coming from
capital eggs and some input coming from
capital y and let's say it just gives
you some number and you imagine that you
have two players Alice and Bob a and B
and Ellis gets one half of the input
let's say Ellis gets the input from
capital X and Bob he gets the input from
capital y and now they want to figure
out what is actually the value of the
function and what they can do is they
can send pit bits to each other and
after some number of bits they should
both know the value of the function okay
there are some differences in whether
there's randomization where the things
should be deterministic
non-deterministic okay so this is a kind
of that the general setup in
communication complexity good so where's
the connection now so imagine like
things are deterministic for a moment
and let's look at what's called the
decision tree so the decision tree is
the following this is at the beginning
of the protocol and then let's say Alice
either sends a 0 or she sends a 1 maybe
then it's Bob Stern then Bob either
sends a 0 or a 1 and so on and the
number of bits they exchanged is the
length of the protocol corresponding to
the the depth of the tree and ok so at
the end of the protocol they are sure
that they both know the value of the
function and ok I should mention that
usually the way to IND this is
interpreted is that it's like the
function corresponds to a matrix and
analyst gets an index gets gets a row
index and Bob gets a column index and
they have to figure out like what's the
entry in the matrix now obviously that's
the same as you know picking out a
function ok so now what happens if if
the protocol kind of goes down this way
so they exchange 0 0 and then they are
sure that they know what's in the matrix
maybe they they are sure that the matrix
entries to then actually Alice doesn't
actually know precisely the input of Bob
she just knows enough to be sure that
there's a - Bob doesn't actually know
what input Alice has he just is sure
enough that the entry should be to the
matrix entries should be to so actually
what happens is that the set of inputs
for Alice and Bob that lead
to to go down this path in the protocol
tree it must be a common toriel
rectangle the value of the matrix must
be the same okay because otherwise there
would be a mistake in the protocol they
couldn't be sure okay so if you think
about this then if you have a protocol
where Alice and Bob exchanged see many
bits then you have to to the C menu
leaves and you can actually you have a
partition of your matrix into to the see
many rank one matrices okay and a
partition of your your matrix into to
the C menu rank one matrices and that
just means you can write your matrix as
2 to the K that was kale many actually
these are non-negative rank one matrices
so this is just a factorization this is
just a non-negative factorization and
this is the the size of your
non-negative vectorization okay it's
just the depth of the 2 to the depth of
the tree the number of leaves of the
tree okay if they decide to send either
1 or 2 bits depending on the result of
previous exchanges for some of the
structure of the tree ok so ok so first
of all the only losing effect referred
moves to in the depth if you require
Alice and Bob to alternate but they
don't have to alternate so it could be
that Alice very sends 0 that later she
will send another bit and if she sends 1
then it's Bob Stern so that would be a
protocol as well
[Music]
okay so uh and I think I did skip this
notation let's say the communication
complexity of a function or of the
matrix it would be just it's the number
of bits you need to exchange in the best
protocol in the shortest protocol okay
so okay so I hope I could convince you
that the following is true so the
extension complexity of a polytope we
just saw that it's actually bounded by
two - the communication complexity of
the slack matrix
it doesn't look very good if you have an
upper bound which is to to the something
but there's a beautiful application for
example to two perfect graphs so the
stable set Polito of perfect graphs
don't think I'll get to that but there's
a nice application where there's a
protocol of I think N and log n square
length and that gives you some
quasi-polynomial upper bound on the size
of the extension complexity of the
stable set Bonito okay
it can't have real yes yes so at the end
they okay in communication complexity in
most cases people study like zero one
functions and there are one major number
of the rows and columns
yes which strings x and y i guess will
have different lengths it's kind of in
some sense the yeah but it's it's it's
irrelevant what's the bit length of x
and y okay so okay so this is the upper
bound i just explained the extension
complexity of a polytope it's upper
bounded by two to the deterministic
communication complexity to figure out a
word entry you have in the slack matrix
i said something about your lower bound
and the lower bound that I gave you was
the rectangle covering number of the
slack matrix okay so that can also be
translated in the language of
communication complexity and directing a
covering number it's actually it's
actually two to the non-deterministic
communication complexity
they're two players need to figure out
whether there is a positive entry in the
slack matrix or not non-deterministic
because it's covered it's not a
partition okay good so staring at this
you see the following is like there's an
upper bound there's some some kind of
protocol that seems to be too strict
there's a lower about that kind of seems
to be like you know give too much room
to the players the question could be is
there actually some kind of model some
kind of communication complexity model
that captures precisely this size here
so the the answer is yes they responded
that some some joint work of Sam was in
the audience I hope he hasn't skipped
the talk and and a couple of other folks
okay on the other nib is not in the
audience I don't have to pay the copier
ah I have to okay okay good so here is
the exact model that corresponds to the
logarithm of the extension complexity of
their non- rank of the slack matrix okay
here we go
uh again two pairs Alice Bob Ellis gets
a row of the slack matrix Bob receives
the column index of the slack matrix now
they run the protocol but they have they
can use randomness so they have their
own infinite pile of random bits and
okay now again they exchange 0 0 1 bits
and at the end are one of them outputs
are number imagine one of them outputs
bright the number on the whiteboard and
it better be non-negative now and what
they need to do is they need to compute
the the entry and the slack matrix in
expectation meaning that over the
randomness of the protocol what the
output on average should be precisely
the value of the second the select
matrix
and that's the right bottle this is
correlated okay am i the equivalents
prove that I'm going to show you they
have internal randomness Oh God there
are some results about like the
difference between like joint randomness
and and and internal randomness but that
workshop was like two workshops ago so
I'll refer to that okay okay so um yeah
I want to show why actually this is kind
of the same and and here we go okay so
again there are two directions and the
proof that I should better show and okay
so let's say okay let's start with one
direction where I have my non-negative
factorization of the slag matrix and
this is a size are non-negative
factorization and now I have to show you
how can I get a log our protocol out of
that that does the right thing okay so
Ellis has an in has just knows the row
of the slag matrix Bob knows the column
of the slag matrix they they have to
compute this entry in expectation and
they have randomness and they should
only use no carpets and here we go ah
Alice does the following she she looks
at her vector UI and she picks a random
random entry but not uniformly sorry
this should be a UI so she she picks the
entry a an entry proportional to what
the value okay so if this is if this is
let's say zero she would never pick it
so this is proportional to the value and
then she sends that index that index
which is a number between 1 and R she
sends that index
to Bob so she uses only la carpets well
Bob gets that index now Bob stares at
his vector and he outputs the value of
his vector and again like via your di I
messed things up here okay good if you
now look at what are they okay l bought
outputs values depending on the
randomness so worry about it what is the
expected value that the outputs all the
expected value well you know you just
write down the expectation what it is
it's you're summing over these are your
events this is the probability of the
event and this is what is being output
in that case but this is precisely
dinner product and the inner product is
what they have to on put okay so not
much happened okay so this is one
direction of the equivalents for the
other direction that works as follows
so imagine imagine this is the protocol
the protocol tree Alex and Bob pay
exchanged see bits and at the end they
they they output on average the the
entry in the slack matrix so if they do
that then where's my factorization that
has size that knows 2 to the C well
let's do the following let's think a
little bit about what what we actually
get so the end of the day what we are
getting is is the entry in the slack
matrix and this is the expectation so we
may end up at every of the leaves Bob or
Alice are going to output some value
that's going to be non-negative there's
gonna be some probability that given
this input I and J the protocol ends up
at that leaf okay good but if you think
about this if you fix a leaf
you you fix some input inj and you're
wondering what's actually the
probability then that we end up at that
that leave then it's actually the
probability that in all the rounds that
belong to Alice you're staying on the
path going down to the leaf and you know
the rounds that belong to Bob you're
also staying on the path that that goes
down to the leaf so these are two
probabilities that you can just that you
you just have to multiply so given I
given Alice's input I you take the
probability that Alice stays on the path
and part given Bob's input J you have
the probability that Bob stays on the
path now looking at this actually what
you have is that you're writing an entry
in this leg matrix as the sum of well 2
to the C many leaves of something or
negative times something or negative
that depends on Alice's input times
something or negative that depends on
Bob's an input and that is precisely
your non negative factorization of size
2 to the C okay
okay so the message is the extension
complexity of polytopes it's the same as
the non- rank of the slack matrix and
the non- rank of a matrix it it is very
much connected to communication
complexity and in particular if you want
to show lower bounds it would be a
really good idea to look into
communication complexity and and see
what what results are there available
okay I have a couple of minutes left so
I think I can talk maybe five minutes
about my the last topic I wanted to
mention and then I'll finish it up in
the next lecture okay good so things
were a little bit abstract let's get a
little bit more concrete and I would
love to show you essentially the first
lower bound on the concrete polytope and
that was actually the correlation
polytope okay and here we go the
correlation polytope it's mathematically
define a new pretty simple way you just
look at the convex hull of all zero one
matrices that have rank one or zero okay
so that's nice to write down for example
in two dimensions we are looking at the
convex hull of you know these matrices
here they have all rank one or zero and
they have only entries zero one okay we
would love to show that any linear
program for this this poly tope has
exponential size that's what we would
like to do so first of all I would like
to mention that this is a poly tope that
np-hard in the sense that if you could
optimize the linear function over that
poly tope you could actually solve NP
hard problems that means that you know
you would expect that there is no small
in your program representing it
you still wouldn't know how to prove
that okay and I think the easiest way to
show np-hardness would be that well if
you if you have any graph on n vertices
and you're if you maximize and I think
this is called the laplacian over the
polytope then what you're actually
getting is the value of the Max cart and
Max card is an np-hard
it's an MPI problem so that's not going
to work okay so this is an MPR Pro it's
an np-hard polytope some sense but we
would like to show that there is no new
linear program of small size okay in
fact that that's a result of Sam and
bizarre piccata was also here Tabari and
the wood and to be precise what they
showed is that the extension complexity
of this poly tope it's it's
exponentially large so it's kind of as
bad as you might fear it should be the
original proof it worked
slightly differently we I would like to
show you a simplified pretoria proof
that was later found by a chi blind belt
and that's one that one can even nicely
teach and some optimization course ok so
ok there's a principle problem if you
want to show a lower bound of this type
for an np-hard problem because what it
means to show a lower bound it means
you're staring at the slack matrix which
is defined by the vertices like these
guys and it's defined by the
inequalities the problem is that what
are the inequalities so it's an MPR
polytope and if you would have a nice
explicit description of all the
inequalities that would actually give
you co MP certificate which is unlikely
to exist so we do it the problem that we
have to show the lower bound of a slack
Maitri
that we don't know okay that's a little
bit of a issue here however what we do
know are some valid inequalities okay so
this is a nice family of valid
inequalities and okay so here we go for
me for some vector a you can do the
following you can take two times the
diagonal matrix of a minus a transpose
and this times any point in that
correlation polytope is at most one
that's the claim okay so why is that
true well okay easy trick if you have to
show that some inequality holds for the
convex hull of things then you just it
suffice as if you show that linear
inequality just for every extreme point
things are little Biggie's yeah so you
can just say that okay this vector here
this is a matrix but it's it's an
extreme point so it's of the form 0 1
vector times itself okay now if you plug
this in here and calculate what you're
getting well I try to give a poor
visualization so what i'm doing here is
like okay this is my vector a you put it
on the diagonal you put it two in front
times that vector BB transpose and okay
okay sorry so you're moving stuff to the
other side and subtracting it from one
so this is a transpose times BB
transpose and I know if you do some
pattern matching here then here what
you're getting is the intersection size
of a and B what you're getting here is
actually the square of the intersection
size of a and B and I'm not sure whether
the picture was actually helpful but
anyway so if you figure this out then
what you're getting is that the slack
that you have if you look at this vertex
and this the inequality belonging to a
then the slack is this one
and all of this this this nice formula
that this actually the square of
something and the square of something
happens to be most of the time on the
negative so this is indeed this is the
valid inequality okay so there's our NPR
polytope we have a now we have a ton of
valid inequalities means that actually
we do know a part of the slag matrix we
don't know all of it but it will turn
out that this part of the slag matrix is
gonna have already a non-negative rank
of 2 to the N and that in the next
lecture will lead to to that lower bound
and okay I think would be a good time to
do some to have a coffee break and I'll
see you again in a bit
[Applause]
okay so the question is the constraints
that I use to fill my slack matrix to
define the slack matrix okay I think I
said let's take the facets you can take
the fact that you can actually just add
any valid inequality that just makes the
slack matrix larger actually it's not
going to change the non-negative rank at
all because you're on each adding Kuni
combinations of existing rows anyway so
you can okay the answer is you can add
any valid inequality in there and it's
not changing the rank of your slack
matrix so just do it so pick up on
David's point so you're just adding a
whole bunch of inequality you don't have
to show any conditions other than their
feasible yes
okay so let's break
[Applause]